all right so i'm cutting the thumbs up
that we are ready to go and i'll
probably need all the time uh that i
have so let's get started um
so good afternoon everybody i hope you
had a great lunch i'm really excited to
be here and to uh talk to you today uh
for one thing this is my first in-person
conference that i've been to in a while
so it's great to be together with you uh
in this nice room here uh and secondly i
get to talk about a topic that i really
like uh classic adventure games um so
that's really cool
um so in this session i will show you
how we can build our own adventure game
with blazer and in.net
so my name is sunder molecamp i'm a
principal cloud architect at infosport
which is a dutch i.t con consulting
company and i'm also microsoft azure mvp
and i've been around for a while i was
born in 1978
so that was just a couple of years after
the first real tax adventure game was
released which was glass of cave
adventure so in this
game you had to explore this mysterious
cave where full of hidden treasures and
this being 1977ish
it didn't have any graphics whatsoever
so this was a real text adventure game
so the game would describe a situation
to you and then you would have to reply
with these one or two word commands and
then you got a hat in the game it would
describe the next situation
now the first game i actually remember
playing was king's quest this was
released in 1984 and at that time
adventure games incorporated real
graphics so you could control your
on-screen character like in frame here
using the cursor keys on your keyboard
but then if you wanted him to do
anything else but walk around you still
had to type in a command like pick up an
object
and that was a bit problematic for me
because at the time when i was playing
this at a friend's house i was like
eight maybe nine years old and my
english vocabulary wasn't that
well it was pretty limited to say the
least so it was pretty difficult for us
to get ahead in the cave
well that became less of problem a
couple of years later so for one thing
we do have some english in our
elementary schools in in the netherlands
so that's certainly helped but also
these adventure games keep evolving
further onto these real point-and-click
adventure games and the first real
example of that is maniac mentioned from
lucasfilm games
so what you see here on the screen is in
the lower part you see all these verbs
and below that you see an inventory of
all the items that the players collected
now instead of having to type commands
you could simply point your mouse and
click on a verb and click on object in a
game and that would execute some player
action so that was much easier for me to
play when i when i was younger
what's also interesting about maniac
mansion is that they created this um
game engine for it called scum or script
creation utility for maniac mention
and that basically allowed the game
designers to write these more abstract
high-level scripts without having to
worry about the actual underlying
platform or the actual hard coded
programming language um it's really nice
as you can see here it's almost like
being a bit of a movie director where
you can just tell your actors to do
stuff and uh it's really it makes it
simple to script such a game
now scum evolved and evolved and it got
used in a lot of the lucasfilm games of
the year
so the mid 80s basically represent the
start of this golden era for adventure
games at least here in the in europe and
over in the us and a lot of the real
classics were uh released during this
golden era which lasted until like the
mid 90s and then it steadily declined
and a lot of first person shooter games
came up like doom and stuff
so this is a favorite of mine it's
called the secrets of monkey island
so what i want to do in this
session and what i
wanted to do initially was to
try to create a game like monkey island
that feels like monkey island that looks
a bit like monkey island with the same
type of gameplay uh but build it
entirely with playground.net
so why blazer well
because i can and because i wanted to
learn blazer so i thought this would be
a nice uh simple application to try to
create in blazer
so blazer it is
um
now i started thinking about how to do
this and in coot
adventure game tradition i came up with
three main tasks
so the first one
is how are we going to actually design
this in in blaze so blaze applications
are entirely composed out of components
so at a high level
the question becomes if i want a ui like
monkey island then
what type of components do i need how do
i design these components now all those
different components interact with each
other
and of course blaze is used to create
web applications and as we all know we
use html and css to sell web
applications but i want something to
look like a real adventure game with
some nice pixelated graphics and stuff
so just using html and a bit of css
probably isn't enough so second
challenge is going to be how do we
render some nice graphics
and then i also really like that idea of
having a separate script interpreter
like maniac mentioned does
so i want to build my own scripts and i
need to have a scripting engine for that
that can dynamically interpret that
script and drive the ui so that's going
to be my first challenge so we will walk
through all of these one by one
starting with blazer
now
you may not know it but we're at a
really special location for a blazer
talk because back in 2017 steve
sanderson from microsoft held a
presentation i think it was actually in
this very same room
about all the cool things that web apps
can do if they run client-side in a
browser
and in one of his demos he showed a
dot-net application with
some razer pages running client-side and
that was really amazing demo and it was
also the first public appearance of what
would later really become or officially
become blazer
so blazer is this framework for building
single page applications with net that
means i can run i can write my code in g
sharp instead of javascript this is
great news for me because i'm a really
lousy javascript developer and i'm at
least a
bit of a decent c-sharp developer
my coding experience is
mostly from back-ends
so now i can reuse those skills to also
build client-side applications which is
really nice
and that also means is that i can reuse
all of those nuget packages that i know
and love and almost all of them will
just work with blazer there are some
exceptions so if you have a nuked
package which uses a certain network
protocol which isn't allowed for my
browser sandbox that may not work but
overall most of them just work as
expected
and what's particularly nice if my
backend's also in
net it's now very easy to share code
between my client and my server and
that's especially nice for things like
message contracts or validation codes
stuff like that
now there are two ways to actually host
a blast application up to now we've
mostly talked about blaze as something
running inside the browser and that's
called blazer web assembly but you can
also run blazer on the server
so to start with laser web assembly web
assembly is basically this instruction
set so what happens is that your
net application gets translated into
these web assembly binary forms
instructions and then your browser can
execute those instructions and now
your.net
application runs in the browser so
that's a really high level overview of
it
the other scenario is hosting blazer on
the server so then your application
actually runs on the server and any
input from the client is being sent to
the server over the signalr connection
so signals is real-time messaging
framework
then your server process executes the
logic and any ui changes are sent back
over that same signal connection back to
the browser and merge into the dom
now blazer server does have some
benefits for example you can pre-render
your content which makes it much more
friendly for search engines that can
then discover your pages
and it also runs on browsers that do not
support uh web assembly although
webassembly sport's pretty good i tried
running it on my iphone
this morning and that works
as well
so for this game i'm definitely going to
use webassembly for two main reasons um
this is a point and click adventure game
so that kind of implies that there will
be a lot of mouse events going on and
it's just way more efficient to handle
those directly in the browser and then
sending them up to some server component
and i also like having no server
component because that means that my
application is basically just a bunch of
static files and it's really easy and
cheap to host that
so web assembly it is okay so let's take
a look at the design of my blazer
application so as i said a blazer
application is composed out of
components so basically everything is a
component and you can think of a
component as reusable uh bits like a
datepick or a text box but also the top
level pages are components themselves
and i'm going to have two top-level
pages in my application i'm going to
have a select game page where the
player can obviously select a game
and then when you select the game you
will be redirected to the play game page
and there you should be able to actually
play the game that you selected
and that should obviously look a little
bit like this
ideally
so for that i'm simply going to identify
a blazer component that will make all of
that happen that will display this ui
and that same component will also be
responsible for loading my game script
and we'll get
to the game script at the third part of
the session into the details but for now
just assume there's a game script
um
so this game view component takes those
that ui and that game script makes sure
that it works together but this is
obviously going to be quite a big
component if it needs to do everything
so we can divide this up into some sub
components
so for example uh if you look at the
lower left bottom you have this area
where the player can
pick a verb
so we can extract that into its own
component call that a fur picker
and then similarly uh over on the right
bottom side we have our inventory view
which is responsible for displaying the
user's inventory
above that we have this action bar and
the action bar displays
the current action that the user can
execute so for example if i were to
click on
let's say look at in defer picker then
the action bar text you'd change to look
at and if i then hovered my maskers over
the shuffle in the inventory view then
the action bar should change to look at
shovel and if i then click on that
shuffle then the action bar should
detect hey i've got a complete command
look at shovel and it somehow needs to
track it to trigger that game script to
1d command
and then i've got one component left
which is the room view which will need
to take care of the rendering of
the scene of the world and that look
into the world is traditionally called a
room in lucasfilm games uh it doesn't
actually matter if the character is in
an actual room or is outside in in force
or something like that it's always
called a room
okay so let's look at one of these
components see what that looks like in
blazer so here's a sample of the verb
picker and as you can see it's basically
a combination of some html some c sharp
and some some razor markup syntax
so what i do here i i first check if it
needs to be visible because at some
points in the game i don't want to show
the the player controls i only want to
show what's happening in the world
if it is visible i will render all those
verbs
i'm only showing three here because
otherwise wouldn't fit on my slide
and then each verb is rendered in a span
i've have a on click handler on that
span so if the player clicks on that
verb that handler will go off and at
that point we should probably let some
of the other components know that the
players clicked on the verb so that they
can react to that
so if i click on a verb one of the
components that needs to know about it
is this action bar right because the
text must be displayed
but there are a lot of other
interactions
for example that action bar also reacts
to the inventory view and the room view
if you mouse over things or click on
things
and then if you actually execute an
action
such as look at shovel
um then that game script must be
triggered
if i click in the room then the game
screen must also be triggered because
the position of my character will change
and the game script needs to know about
it
when the game script runs the actual
game logic
the ui needs to be updated to reflect
those changes in the game script state
so there are also a lot of interaction
going the other way
so all in all there's a lot of
interaction going on so to
fix that or to implement that in a
nicely loosely coupled way i decided to
use a really simple pops up
pattern and implement that in a mediator
object
so as an
example let's say that i click on pickup
and then i click on a newspaper object
in the in the world
then the action bar will detect that oh
you want to pick up the newspaper i'm
going to execute a player action for
that so it will create an execute player
action command and it will send that to
the mediator
and then my game view component
is subscribed to that command so it will
receive the command from the mediator
the game view components also
responsible for managing the game script
so my game script here is just an
ordinary.net object it's not that blazer
component
so the game view will call the game
script
and then the game script will do
whatever is scripted and it will start
sending these events to update ui so for
for example it may send an item added to
inventory newspaper send it using that
mediator again and then my inventory
view is subscribed to that event
because once an item is added to the
inventory it must be displayed on the
screen so now it can do that
um so keep in mind that there's no
messaging infrastructure underneath this
media that is just an in uh memory pops
up implementation i think the whole
mediated code is like 60 lines of code
something like that
all right so let's look at some of the
code see how we use that mediator so
this is the
source code for the play game page
and at the top you can see it has this
page directive so this is basically the
route for the for the page and that
includes a disk number so this number is
just my unique identification for a game
so i know what game you want to play
then i inject the mediator into this
instance so the mediator is registered
with the dot-net dependency injection
framework and then i get an instance
here that i can use in i play game page
now if you look down a little bit in
html you can see there's my game view
component
and then if you would look into this
game view component you would see the
other components like a fur picker info
view and so forth
but it's surrounded by this cascading
value element
so why do i need that
the cascading value
element basically makes that mediator
instance available to all of the nested
components with within that
cascading value element so now my game
view but also the other deeper nested
components can all have access to that
mediator object
so let's see what that looks like in one
of these components so let's
dive into the game view component
here again at the top you see some stuff
being injected i won't go into it i need
it i need those classes to load a game
then i check if the game script has any
errors
if it does i render those on the screen
because it will make it my life much
easier to debug it
but otherwise everything went well i can
render my ui and my ui consists of these
other four
components
now if we scroll down a little bit in
this file we can all see the c sharp
code and there we can see a parameter
for that mediator and the parameter is
decorated with the gas gaining parameter
attribute and because this is a gas
getting parameter it will get that value
from that gas gaining value that i
defined in page so it will now have this
mediator and i didn't give give the
guest getting value a particular name so
the matching here is based on the type
which is imediator
now
why do i need these guest gaining
parameters here because i could have
also injected the mediator into this
component right just like i did with the
page component and i could also inject
it into these deeper nested components
like like the verb picker
well have a look at this scenario
so let's say i'm playing a game game
number one
and i decide i want to quit the game and
i want to go play another game so i go
back to the selection screen
my play game page including all of the
nested components will now be disposed
because i'm on a different page
so now i'm going back to the play game
page but another instance a new instance
of the play game page to play game two
so what happens with the mediator
instance well it kind of depends how i
register it with the dependency
injection framework
because it depends on the lifetime that
i give it and in blaze or webassembly
you can choose between singleton
lifetime or trench in lifetime
you there's no concept of scopes in
place of web assembly so if i define a
or i register a dependency as scoped i
simply get the same behavior as
singleton
which is always give me back the same
exact same instance of of the mediator
and i don't want that because if
my
page 2 gets the same instance that was
used for
page 1
that won't work because that mediators
all kinds of registrations on it for
components that don't exist anymore so i
definitely don't want that
so maybe i should register it as
transient
well i don't want that either because
then every component will get its own
version of the mediator and they won't
be able to talk to each other because
everybody's talking to his own mediator
to which nobody is subscribed so what i
really want is i actually want the
lifetime of the mediator to be tied to
the lifetime of my blazer page
and i can do that if i look quickly at
the play game source code again i can do
that by registering my media address
transients so that each time i go to the
play game page i get a new
but then using that guess getting
failure with cascading parameters to
pass down that same exact instance to
all of my nested components and that
will make sure that everybody is talking
using the same mediator
okay back to my game view
so of course now we have our mediator
object but now we need to subscribe to
messages coming in from that mediator
and a good place to do that is this
uninitialized method so this method is
called once when your component is
created and it's called after the
parameters have been set so i can be
sure that i have my mediator object
now it registers a handler called
onstartgame async and if i scroll down
even more then you can see that here on
the screen
so what i do in this handler
i first try to load my game manifest
using the disk number now the game
manifest is just this simple yaml file
that i created that contains
the locations of the scripts and the
images that my game uses because i need
to know where they are i need to load
them in
so i try to load that manifest file
and then i publish it
in this game manifest loaded event and
that's just to make sure that any other
components in my game which may also
need the game manifest can now subscribe
to this command and or event and has
access to it
so then i load the actual game script
from the manifest and if that succeeded
i can run that script and then the
script will take off it will start
publishing events and it will basically
drive the ui from that point forward
so
that's all nice and well
um but we still need somebody to
actually trigger that start game come on
because because this will only be set in
motion if that start game is actually
sent to the mediator
and that's done in the back in the play
game page
so in the play game page
after rendering
has happened i triggered that first
start game command and this on after
render async method has this really nice
parameter first render which you can use
to check if it's the first time that the
component is rendered because i only
want to start a game once of course
so i check that
variable first before i send it
now
i do need to make sure
that when i send my first
command
that all of the other components
have already created their subscriptions
on the mediator because if they didn't i
can send a command but nobody is
listening or they may miss some messages
now if you remember in the game few
components
that subscription was done in the
uninitialized method
but there are actually two versions of
of the uninitialized method in blazer
there's this synchronous version which
you see here on the slide
there's also an asynchronous version
called uninitialized async
and in this sample i've added some long
running operations let's say we're
loading in a lot of data from a database
or something something that will be
really asynchronous and will take a
while
so what has happened now is that now my
uninitialized async method returns an
incomplete task
and the thing to remember here is that
blazer will not wait for your incomplete
task to complete before it starts
rendering
and that's actually a good thing
because it allows you to render things
like a progress bar or a spinner while
you are doing a lot of asynchronous
setup code or uninitialized so it's a
good thing but
we need to make sure
that we
subscribe to the mediator before calling
any async code
and if we do that then we can be sure
that all that synchronous setup code is
done before we reach this point in the
code which is the on after render
point
all right
so let's
show you something that actually works
uh let me take my time here okay so this
is my first demo it's called cheese
quest
a lot of these games were ending in the
name quest
um
so this is my select game page right so
it's basically uh shows the title of my
engine which came with from 4000 and
then it shows all the games that it has
found and that i can play
so if i click on demo one cheese quest
you can see that's the uh
in the url this is the play game page
and this is disk number two
now
it doesn't show much yet but it does
show it does do some things right so if
i open my console
you can see that there are already
flowing some effects events through that
mediator so for example here we can see
the game manifest was loaded then the
game was started then the protagonist
was changed now we don't see a
protagonist on the screen yet because we
don't have graphics but
behind the scenes a protagonist was
selected with the character that you
play with
and then a room was entered now again
the room is pretty dark and
it's basically a black void but the
mediator stuff is working and also
communications between these
laser components are working so for
example if i
click on the look adverb
you can see that a event verb selectors
has been published and that the action
bar now displays the text lookup
look at
and if i go over these you can all
see that this
or interacts together and there's even a
little bit of gameplay in this
amazing game you can use a cheese grater
with a block of cheese and then of
course you get some
grated cheese so it's truly amazing what
you can do with modern technology yeah
um now obviously um this doesn't look a
bit like monkey island yet we've got
this huge black fort up on the screen so
we need to do
some graphics so let me
press q here and that will take me back
to the select game page and i can go
back to my slide deck
so this brings us neatly into trial
number two
uh how are we going to render those
graphics
well i'm going to use a library for that
because i obviously don't want to start
from the beginning so i'm going to use
phaser for that which is this really
great html5
gaming framework that i've also already
used for a bunch of other stuff
it uh gives you things like sprites and
animations and input events it is it
also has some more sophisticated stuff
like particle engines and textures and
all kinds of cool stuff so for example
if i load in a sprite sheet it's a
sprite sheet from our main character is
called guys country um if i give this
sprites sheet to face her and i set up
some options then facebook can animate
it for me and i get this nice walking
character
now i can draw
this is actually
something that a buddy of mine edwin
from mike drawed but we just took the
original monkey island sprite sheets and
we draw over them with with some
different colors and then you get these
nice original characters without having
to have any creative skills at all so
that's very nice now the bad news here
is that
phaser is a javascript library
and i already mentioned to you that i
don't like writing javascript
uh but fortunately blazer provides some
very nice features to integrate our.net
code with javascript script and that way
keep the bulk of my code on the.net side
but first let's have a quick look at
some javascript code to see how you
actually create a sprite in phaser it's
pretty easy it's basically this one one
liner
so you call scene.sprite you give the
location for the sprite
alien is the name of my sprite sheet and
then front is the name of the image in
that sprite sheet and that will give me
this alien here which is not a character
from the game
now
this will give me a sprite but
oftentimes i want to set up some of my
additional options for that sprite so
for example maybe i want to set the
depth so the depth is basically the the
z index or the z index so higher numbers
uh sprites with a high number depth will
be drawn on top of sprites with a lower
number depth
maybe i want the sprite to be
interactive that means it can receive
mouse events like pointed down pointer
over pointer out
and pixel perfect here means
don't send any mouse events for the
transparent pixels so that's the
alignment is perfect
and then if i have mouse events then
obviously it's going to be interesting
if i can also handle those so here i
register an event handler for a point
down event and i simply uh lock a
message to the console
so this is a little uh
face of javascript 101 how you set up
this price so how are we going to call
this from our.net code
well blazer provides you with this
ijs runtime abstraction that we can use
to do that
so how it works is from my.netcode i can
call invoke void async give it the name
of a javascript function that i want to
invoke
give it a bunch of parameters that i
want to invoke it with
and then ijs runtime will
marshal that to javascript and it will
invoke that function for me
now a couple of things to notice here
that function name is relative to the
global windows scope
and all of the parameters that you pass
must be json serializable or otherwise
this won't work
um you can also uh get a return value
from javascript so there's also this
info async of t overload which you can
use for returning values and uh
the same holes here that return favor
must be serialized by as well
now
each of these invocations will
incur a little bit of overhead
because of that serialization
so it's general rule of thumb is it's a
good thing to keep the number of uh
interoperable invocations quite low
so
the way i try to do that
is by adding this facade to phasor right
as we already saw i need multiple calls
to phasor to set up a sprite so let's
add a facade layer which i can call it
with just a single call so my face or
interrupt.js file contains
functions like this add sprite with
really a bunch of parameters and then it
will
make multiple calls to phaser to set up
my sprite
so
that
is a javascript file that i had to write
fortunately it's pretty easy to write
because it's just it just calls some
facial apis and it's not too bad it's
like 200 250 lines of code the rest of
the code's all too sharp
so now for my.net goes i can simply
invoke the single function and i save a
bunch of interrupt calls
and there's another optimization i can
make here
because
let's go back one if you look
between.net and ij's runtime at the
invoke void async call that's an
asynchronous call and the main reason
that's async is to allow for blazer
server scenarios because if your
application is running on the server and
you want to call javascript in the
browser you definitely need to call over
the network
but if i run in a blazer web assembly
and i'm running in the browser next to
the javascript engine i don't need that
to be asynchronous i can make this
asynchronous call so i can actually cast
ij as runtime to ijs in process runtime
um and on ij in process runtime i can
invoke synchronous calls and that saves
a little bit of overhead if you make a
lot of
calls it's i think it's around four or
five times faster than uh the async
versions
all right
next demo
um
this is not going to be an exciting demo
i can tell you already um
so here we are at the first room of of
the game and now we have our protagonist
guys guthrie on screen so that's great
um and we also have a new spray pair
lying next to the bench so this is not
part of the background this is a sprite
so what i've done here is basically just
add some sprites to the screen right
but it's not interactive yet
so i can still select a verb in this
verb picker to look at something but if
i now hover over this this newspaper
nothing happens
and why is that well
that's because we've created some code
to call javascript from.net but we
haven't done anything to call.net from
javascript so all the mouse events that
face the fires nobody's listening to
them yet so that's going to be the the
next part let's handle those mouse
events and see if we can actually
because i cannot even move around in
this in this demo see if we can make
this better
so let's go back
and let's go back to my slides okay so
what i want is i want to be able to
write handlers like this so when my
pointer is down so when i click on a
game object i want
to be able to invoke some piece of
netcode that can then handle that event
now to make
any dotnet method invocable from
javascript it needs at least two things
it needs to be a public method
and it needs to have this js invokable
attribute
and then you can
you can call it from javascript and you
can see in this sample i have this point
point position which is the mouse
position uh that obviously also has to
be um serializable for it to work
now
i i've got a lot of these events i want
to handle and i don't particularly like
having these public decorated methods at
various places in my code so what i did
was i added a additional helper class
called my face callback clasp and what
this does is it
takes a ordinary.net
an action in this case
and it makes that delicate invocable
from javascript by adding this public
method decorating it with a js invokable
so now if my javascript code calls this
a callback then this callback class will
call my action and the action can be
whatever i want it to be
on the net side and i also have two
other variations of this class one
for the case where javascript needs to
pass an argument another one where i
want to pass an argument but also want
to get a return value back
so let's say i have an action which
which is a callback for some code that
needs to happen when my pointer is down
i wrapped that action
in a phaser callback
object to make the invokable from
javascript but now my javascript code
needs to have a reference to this
callback because otherwise how will it
invoke it and i can get a reference by
calling.netobjectreferencecreate.net
object reference is a blazer class which
gives me
a
reference object which i can pass over
to the javascript side
and i can do that for example in the add
sprite function so when i add a sprite
very first time i call that javascript
function to do that and one of the
parameters will be this on point
downgrade so if you go to javascript
site here's my add sprite function in my
phaser interrupt file that will get that
on points downref
it will create the sprite set it up
then it will register
an event handler for the point to down
event and in that event handler it can
call invoke method on that on points
down reference which will inform my face
a callback which will invoke my action
which contains the actual
net code that it wants to to execute
so now
we should be able to
have some interaction
so for example i can walk around in this
room
and
i don't know if you can see it clearly
it's it's a bit subtle in this room but
if i walk to the back of the room i also
scale the character a little bit just to
get a sense of depth in
here and i could do things like uh look
at
this other sprite here this stuff crate
so if i click here
guy will walk to it and we'll uh
say something about it now you can see
that that the character is drawn behind
the crate which is correct
in this case so i do a little bit of
depth sorting based on the bottom y
coordinates of the sprite so if the if
that failure is higher than i draw it on
on top of sprites with lower value
um
and it looks all right if i show it to
you now but if i do
things like this then
it kind of looks a little bit funky i
don't know what's happening here
so guy now has a higher y index than the
top crate so it will be drawn on top and
actually let me try yeah i can also walk
on the
ceiling of this thing so
still not quite there yet uh with the
graphics
okay so let's fix that
um let me go back
slides
okay what's going on here so
we can fix this by defining the area
where the character is actually allowed
to walk and we can call that a walk box
so this is the walk box for the for the
room that you just saw and you can see
this cut out at the bottom that's where
those grates are so i don't want them to
be inside the crates
so let's say that i click on any of
these three points
how am i going to move to those points
well it's trivial because those points
have direct line of sight from the
position where the character is
currently uh at so we can just uh start
play the animation move the sprite to
that new location and we'll be done
but what if the player clicks outside of
the walk box let's say at the red dot
well again it's not that difficult to
solve we can just snap it to the nearest
position on the walk box and then again
there's direct line of sight so we can
just move the character there and that
feels pretty natural when you when you
play the game
but what if i click in the lower left
position because hey now there's no line
of sight anymore
and the problem obviously is those
are these two vertices here
so these are concave vertices in this
walk box polygon and that basically
means they are inward turns
and they make it impossible
uh for all the possible points to be
able to see each other directly
so i need to route around them and the
way i'm doing that is i take those
vertices all the all the concave
vertices in the polygon i add the
position of the player and i add the
position of the mouse cursor because
that's the point where we want to go to
and i then connect all of the points
that are in direct line of sight of each
other so i get this nice graph
and then it's pretty easy to solve
because i can use a well-known
shortest path algorithm over this graph
to find the routes to the location
and i didn't even need to implement
those myself because i'm writing the
netcode and i know of this nougat
package that i've used sometimes called
quick graph which includes a number of
those algorithms like a star and dextra
and being dutch i obviously use dijkstra
so if i move this mouse cursor
and i break that line of sight from the
actor
i can still run that algorithm and find
the shortest path and that also works
even if i go all the way down there
but let me prove it to you that it
actually works
um let me see
this was resisted
okay so
let me first go all the way down here
and then go to the lower left position
and you see guy walking around those
boxes
i also cannot go all the way down here
anymore and i also cannot
go to the roofs so that works pretty
nice now
i've built in this debug mode
where you can see the actual walk box
and if i move the mouse cursor around
you can see what happens
because it will change that graph
and the the green line indicates that
the line that i'm going to take so if i
go all the way down here
to the left you can see that it finds
that path
now
this is a pretty simple room let let's
go explore this ufo a little bit further
let's go around this
podcast booth here now what's that doing
in the
ufo so this is a quite more elaborate
walk box you can see there's also this
alien bit in way but you can see that we
can walk around him
quite well let's try to oh i don't want
to talk to you yet
you can also see the scaling effects uh
better in this room
so yeah wall boxes are fun and they work
great
all right
let's see how am i doing on time 18
minutes okay
so now we have graphics um
now we just need that scripting engine
and some game scripts to actually drive
the game and implement some of the game
launching right
um
now almost everything is sharp
and i want to keep it that way so i'm
going to uc sharp script for the um for
the scripting engine
and that will look a little bit like
this
so to add a room
i can call this add room method and i
give it the an identifier for the room
then i have this like um fluorine
builder like pattern which you can use
to set up some additional settings for
that room so in this case i call the
with walk box area to specify the walk
box area for the room
now in the same way i can add actors to
the game so here i'm adding the main
actor guy
and i make him untouchable because i
don't want you to be able to to click on
the main character viewers because you
are the main character
and then i also add a newspaper uh in
this case i give them a bit of a more
descriptive name so that's the name
you'll see when you mouse over uh mouse
over it
the basic difference here by the way
between an item and an actor is that an
actor can also walk and talk whereas an
item is just a well basically a
non-livable
thing
and then i can add some codes uh that i
want to run when the game first starts
and i can register that code in my on
game start methods so in this
callback
i place both guy and the newspaper in my
park room and then i tell the game
engine that guy's my main protagonist so
now the game engine knows who who you
are controlling and then i tell the
commenting to change the room to the
park
and the engine actually checks if you've
set a protagonist and you set a room
because otherwise it wouldn't know what
to do or just draw an exception
so let's look at that um newspaper in
the or note let me explain something
else because if you look at those
methods at room at actor on game star
those look like static methods right
because there aren't called on a class
well actually there are called on a
class there's this hidden global game
object
and that's the object that implements or
declares all these methods
so what happens is when this game script
runs
the game object gets called and it will
build up this in-memory model of the
game containing all those callbacks like
the on-game start callback
so i only need to run this game script
once when i'm loading the game
once i've run it i've got the in-memory
model and that's used for the
duration of the game
so now let's look at the newspaper
script
because you can also use the script to
script behavior
so let's say when i want to look at the
newspaper
i can use that same fluent interface to
define what must happen when you look at
this particular object and in this case
i first check to see if guy has picked
up the newspaper i can do that by
calling the has method on an actor and
if he did i say it's yesterday's paper
if he didn't i let him say something
about newspaper lying on the ground and
i could do the same for other verbs so
for example when you call pickup on this
item i add it to the inventory of guy
so
again it's it's really more like a movie
script you've got these nice high level
uh
instructions you don't need to worry
about how this is actually implemented
in the code you can just be concerned
with your game logic and what actually
happens under the hood if you call any
of these functions like say line
is that it generates events
so if i call say line it generates a
line spoken event
those events are then published using
mediator and of course our blazer ui
components are subscribed to those
events and they can render the graphics
that are needed to uh to to display the
the reaction
all right so
how are we going to compile that script
into something that runs in my blazer
application uh well i'm going to use
rosslyn for that and
part of rustling is this microsoft code
and also see sharp package which has a
very nice c-sharp script that evaluates
async static methods which you can use
to execute some c sharp codes so really
easy
the only downside is it doesn't work in
blaze or webassembly
if you run this you get a not sport
exception can create a metadata
reference to an assembly without a
location
okay so what's happening here well
rustling will try to get metadata
references for some of the core
assemblies for example the assemblies
that implement the object type because
you need those references to in order to
be able to execute c sharpens your
sharpscript
so it will query the
property for that
and
normally assembly.location will return
the location of your assembly file where
it is on disk
but in web assembly there isn't a file
system there isn't a disk
so
assembly does location will simply
return an empty string and wrestling
doesn't know what to do with it so it
just throws it's not support exception
okay so to fix this
we will need to
go a level deeper and use some of the
lower level wrestling classes too to
make this happen
and it's a bit of code but
works kind of great once you have it
so first let's try to load those
metadata references
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
basically iterate over all of the
assemblies that are currently loaded in
my application
and i will create metadata references
for them all so my script will have
access to the exact same assemblies
there's probably a bit too much for what
the script needs to do but
it's easy to write this way
so i iterate over those assemblies
and i then need to load the assembly now
all those assemblies are stored in this
underscore framework folder in my blazer
application
but again no file system so i need to
get at those using an http client so i
make an http client get request that i
get a response back i can read that
response as a stream and from that
stream i can create a metadata reference
and then i have my list of metadata
references that i can give to to
rustling
okay so next step actually compile my
script
so the first thing i need to do is i
need to use the sharp syntax tree to
create a syntax tree for my source code
i then set a couple of compilation
options
so for example i want to create a
dynamically linked library and also set
some implicit usings and this is nice
because
that means that the author of the game
script doesn't need to include explicit
usings for some of these often used
namespaces
then i create a new script compilation
that needs to have a name i just created
a guide for that
i need to specify the type of my globals
object which is that game object that i
talked about so i specify that and then
i just specified the options the
references
and the syntax tree
and i'm good to go
so then i can call cat diagnostics and
that will return any errors that may
have happened during compilation so if
there aren't any let's assume there
aren't any
i'm ready to run the c-sharp script
and for that i need to have an assembly
so what i can do i can call
compilation.emit
to emit the il code the generated il
code into a stream and then i can use
that stream to loadon in memory assembly
and then i need to have an entry point
and i need to know which method do i
need to call on that assembly to
actually run the script
and with c-sharp script the assembly
contains a script class with this really
weird looking factory method including
brackets
and that's my entry point so that's the
method i need to call and then the
script will run
so i create a delegate for that to make
it easier to invoke
and as you can see here the delicate has
a parameter or i should say the factor
method takes a parameter of type object
array and that's a very special object
array
the first entry in that array must be my
global subject so that's an instance of
my game object
and then what rustling does so each time
i invoke the entry point it kind of
makes the state machine and and
it stores that state machine in this
submission array so i must make sure
that the submission array is large
enough for the number of times i call
the entry point in this case i'm only
going to call the entry point once
so it's good enough to have an array
length of 2 here
and then i can just do it and the
scriptural one
my
object model will be created and
everything will be fine
so now i have
my in-memory object model of the game
the rooms the actors and items and
the game can run but wouldn't it also be
nice if we
allow the player to also maybe create
safe games
and
load games because if you only have save
games it's not that useful
so how we can how how can we do that
um
so what i do is as soon as the game
starts
i create a snapshot of that object model
so i have a snapshot of the state of the
model and here's a json representation
of that of a really small part so here
we have an item called a fridge
the fridge is at a certain position the
status is closed so the door is closed
then i also have guy our main actor he's
also at a certain position
he's facing the camera which
which means that's his front and then i
have this ufo and it contains both guy
and the fridge
now let's say that i'm playing the game
and i'm moving guy over to the fridge
and i open the fridge and then i want to
save the game because i want to save
often because some of these
these adventure case were really brutal
and you had to save basically after
every action you did
so now i take a second snapshot of my
object model
and some things will have changed
so now the fridge is open
and now guy is at a different position
and he's facing away from the camera
he's probably facing the fridge at this
position
but also a lot of other things have
stayed the same right the ufo still
contains a guy in the fridge the fridge
is still at the same position
so i only need to save that diff so i
dip those two snapshots and this is
going to be my safe game and what i do
when i load the game i start from that
initial state and then i add in this
div and then i have the point in the
game where the player left off
so
now obviously when i want to save a game
when i close my browser come back the
next day open on my browser i would
prefer it if my safeguard was still
there right
so where are we going to store this save
game
there are a couple of options i could
introduce at this point a server
component and put it in um i don't know
maybe a azure blob storage or create a
net backend that saves it in the sql
database something like that but i
really don't want to introduce a server
component in my application
i could put it in application storage
which would would probably work fine
there's a limit in the browser
application storage of like five
megabytes but these save games aren't
really that big
but let's say they are big and let's say
there are a lot of safe games there may
be five megabytes just enough well
there's another option called index db
which is this nosql data store
built into basically all modern browsers
and
with indexeddb you don't really have
space limitations more limitation of the
browser itself how much hard disk it
wants to use of your of your entire hard
disk
um
and there's a javascript api for indexed
db that i can use so i can use a bit
more of that javascript interoperability
to call indexeddb
but fortunately i don't have to in this
case because there's this very nice
tj.blast.indexdb nougat package
which already does the hard work for me
now it is a pre-release package um and
it hasn't been
updated in about a year so i
feel like that's not an ideal
combination of things but it works for
my situation so i'm using it
so let's
have a quick look at final came and see
if this truly works
so i'm going to load this up and i'm
going to again
open my
dev tools
and i'll go to
application
and here in the application you can see
all kinds of interesting stuff in here
you've got the indexeddb so if i open up
indexeddb
you can see that i've got a cameratron
database and in that gamertron database
i have a savegametable and let me make
this a little bit bigger
in
game the
i have a single save game already stored
and here is that state now the one thing
i don't like about this is that you see
a lot of nil values
so every fair everywhere you see a nil
value that basically means it hasn't
changed from the initial state and
ideally i would serialize it in a way
that wouldn't include all those new
fields but i haven't come around
to do that with indexeddb so basically
this is my save game so let me close it
up now i also have it come around to
create an actual ui for this so i can
use some global hotkeys i can press s to
save a game and l to load a game so
trust me when i say i'm now pressing the
l button
and that takes me
to a scene further in the game where i'm
in this ufo and you can also see i have
this new newspaper which wasn't in my
inventory before
so this works pretty good and just to
show you it really works let's walk to a
different location i'm going to press s
to save the game
then i'm going to move to another
location again
and i'm going to press l
and i should teleport back to that
location where i previously saved the
game
so that works very well i think now
this opens up an interesting scenario uh
because um i'm debugging this game
script quite often and sometimes i want
to make some changes i do a bit of of
hot reloading basically of my game
script and i can do that by just
creating a snapshot loading the game
script and restoring uh that snapshot
again
so let's
see if that actually works let's walk
all the way over to this
podcast booth so right now if i look at
the podcast booth
guy turns around it says hey it's
podcast booth
okay so maybe i want to change that
behavior so let me go over to
visual studio
so here's my solution is the blaze ui i
also have a core and an infrastructure
project
if i
drill down in the blazer ui you can see
that in my www folder i have this games
folder which are numbered by disk number
and disk one is my game
i can go to the scripts folder and
here's all my c sharp script
for the items in the game so if i now
look for item podcast booth
here is the current script for the
podcast booth so it's an item named
posca boost
it has a certain actual interaction so
this is to set up the reaction of the
protagonist to the object so this is why
guy changes uh it's back to us when it
starts interacting with the booth
and then here's that line it's a podcast
boot so let's say i want to do something
else let's say i want to turn him around
so i want let's say or
it's already turned around right so i
wanted to turn back to the camera face
camera
and then i want them to say something
like hey they
must have oh man i can't talk in live
session must have beamed it up from ndc
oslo
okay let me fix this double space for my
ocd um let's save this um
go back here and now i'll press r for
reload
refreshing game script or r for refresh
i guess that works as as well
now i can say look at
podcast booth
it's a podcast booth
so this is a a real live save for when
you are creating a script sir i should
say
all right
so with that
um
our trials are done and i think we've
succeeded quite well in in creating our
own adventure game
i've got a couple of links for you so
this is so open source um you can get
the source code i just updated it this
morning
i was actually still working on the
demos last night and this morning so i'm
still tweaking quite a bit if you look
at the source code there are really a
lot of to-do's still in there but hey
it's there for you to uh for your
pleasure um you can also play the game
at this url here if you do and if you
succeed in in finishing it it's it's
really a pretty short game
please let me know you can reach me on
twitter i would love to hear from you
um if you think okay i'm interested in
blaze about what else all this adventure
game stuff um i also have a more typical
blazer example in the eshop on developer
repos story
which is basically an e-shop where you
can buy some some t-shirts and stuff so
you can see how a blaze application
would work in a more realistic
scenario
last thing i want to block i've also
have a youtube channel to get with my
buddy edwin from mike it's
called.netflix we talk about all kinds
of microsoft stuff
so that might be interesting to you as
well with that thank you so much for
joining me and have a great rest of the
conference
and if you have any questions i'll be
i'll stick around here or otherwise
outside the room for a while
you